[Music]
tracy's in north carolina hi tracy
welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys how's it going great what's up
well i feel like y'all are brothers i've
been listening to you for over 20 years
since that free friday wow back in the
day
yes and my baby's now 21 so um and i
just bought your book today so i'm so so
excited cool
um yeah so anyway um i'm kind of uh um
you're welcome i have a kind of a
bittersweet um
question a good dilemma bad dilemma sort
of um i'm 51 years old and i am in baby
step seven however it's consequently
because of a divorce
it was um amicable we did not use a
lawyer i was happy with what i got he
was happy with what he got but um
what i did was i took
my portion and with that i bought a um
a three hundred thousand dollar paid for
home
um and i also put my um emergency fund
in place twenty thousand dollars
and i do have three hundred thousand
dollars in my 401k
and so um that that's the kind of
the sweet part um i paid a lot of taxes
but because i've been a stay-at-home mom
for 21 years i do have an education
degree
i now find myself set up with no debt no
payments for the rest of my life but
i'm starting all over again in my career
and i'm scared and i'm
happy and sad and i can't do my happy
little debt free screen because i didn't
really do it that way and so i'm just
i'm just here i am a baby step seven and
i'm like
i i don't even have an encore career
because i really never had a career hey
it's not art it's math
i don't care if it's ugly you're dead
free i'm sorry how you got there too but
you're still there yeah ugly counts
how soon tracy do you have to start
bringing in income
what's your time okay uh
great question okay so i will be
receiving um right now and i'm saying it
kind of shameful but
this all just recently happened and so
right now i am i have um i'm living off
of what he's giving me and i will get
that for two more years and that's only
40 000 a year but because i don't have
any payments i'm i'm putting a lot away
and i'm living off of that but i really
want to start working and not have a
negative like oh my gosh negative
work sure oh and i'm very motivated i'm
very ambitious but i'm scared and yeah
all right so hold on a second let's
address the fear first because i think
the fear has got you all discombobulated
the fact of the matter is is that you
didn't lose whatever talent or skill you
had the last time you worked 21 years
ago
you have all kinds of experience over
that 21 years of of being a homemaker
and everything else that is also still
there and so you have to understand that
you aren't just this newbie that's
walking in with nothing to offer that's
the first thing i'm just real quick just
we gotta have a very little bit of time
just tell me is there an idea or two
that you've had that that you at least
are interested in trying knowing you
don't have to commit the rest of your
work life to it
yes i would love
honestly i would love to be back in the
classroom but i and i'm not
saying this just because i got you all
on the line but i would love to teach um
your course to children
um middle school um but i i'd love to
get back in the classroom again but
but what i get afraid thinking of you
know that i'm new at it again
listen tracy listen to me here's the
reality i i don't know the north
carolina numbers but i know the national
numbers we're seeing record numbers of
teachers
that are moving on as well
for for the same reasons that a lot of
other people are moving on in this great
resignation they are looking for talent
all the time to come in the education
system the reality is you have a degree
which means you've got the baseline of
qualifications you need to get out there
and start talking to anybody and
everybody who knows a school board
member a principal these are all your
friends family members you have all
kinds of relationships tracy in
wilmington north carolina you are
qualified at a base level get in the
school system and start working even if
you got to be a receptionist at the
front desk and you make relationships i
don't i know she won't have to but my
point is is i'm opening it up get in the
school system get back in
and then move into it